ما بدأ كآلام في البطن، إسهال، حمى، تعرق
ليلي، تحول إلى
محنة طبية لمدة 16 شهرًا
لامرأة تبلغ من العمر 64 عامًا في نيو ساوث ويلز بأستراليا، وتبين أن
سبب تلك الأعراض
هو دودة مستديرة يبلغ طولها ثمانية سنتيمترات
تعيش في دماغها، هذا
الطفيلي بالتحديد  تم العثور عليها في ثعابين السجاد
ولم يُعرف أبدًا أنها تصيب
الإنسان قبل أن يعتقد الأطباء أن
العدوى جاءت على الأرجح من براز الثعبان
ولم يروا حالة كهذه
من قبل وماكس لقد أرسلت ذلك إلى الفريق
هذا الصباح
يجب أن نقول إنها  حسنًا، الحمد لله، كنت أشعر
بالإحباط بعض الشيء، أنا متأكد من ذلك، لكنها
جمعت الأعشاب من
حول البحيرة حيث كان لديهم ثعبان، لذلك
يعتقدون أن هذا هو ما حدث كل شيء
ولكن في الواقع عمل طبي رائع من قبل
الفريق في الجامعة بالتأكيد